you know I don't in jail let's not make
that face though let's have more fun
well I never turns it off she's aware of
the camera no she turned off in the
upper one seat looking my boy a ride
turn it off sons in his eyes - squish -
besides a man give a [ __ ] how about how
about that picture you posted of Tom
Brady I said here's your grade score
record vault unbelievable hashtag Oh
hashtag the biggest dick energy energy
he's about as muscular as Leonardo
DiCaprio they have the same body he and
Leo look at that and he works out
constantly
he works out calm did you see the doc on
him on Facebook she he looks like he
literally works out non-stop his wife is
like I hope he retires because this one
works out non-stop and he was like he'll
assault is all I care about
she looks like his mom and he's a
overgrown 12 year old who's in a bad
mood and he's been told to take a
timeout because he's been beating up all
the other kids cause he's taller yeah
it's like a c-section underneath his
belly I don't know what's going on there
bro appendix I think oh yeah might be
appendix either way it's not a bad body
it's not a bad thing best quarterback of
all time
yeah you know what but but what what's
[ __ ] joe Montana's body looked like
do we know with his shirt off uh Montana
was a little essay on Montana was pretty
[ __ ] bringing up Joe Montana
John Taylor was better than that but
Terry Bradshaw was I've never seen him
and uh he's shredded yeah Joe Montana
well that'd be there bro what do you
want her Montana had a body you know you
can type in uh yeah there you go dunking
basketballs everything else yeah but
that doesn't matter
Oh guys don't basketball sounds not good
yeah Troy Aikman big muscular
you know damn Murray you know not
exactly gonna win that mr. Olympia ether
no that's what people to understand its
athletes like the like I'm are shocked
when I get to the NFL Rock locker room
I'm
Division one college locker room and I
was looking around like I thought
everyone would look like LeBron James I
thought literally everyone's like that
that's not the case this is just not the
way it works
Lea fado are one of the greatest
fighters athletes of all time he looks
like [ __ ]
he looks like [ __ ] polysemy [ __ ] fast
[ __ ] Charles Barkley was when he was 300
pounds really overweight was dunking out
of the gym they saw Charles white used
to be skinny though
so did Shaq like they were tight there
and well he's just fat but even before
like a collie played for Hughes no one
even called you since K when he was on
the rocket - and Suns he was pretty skin
there is for the six or C yeah yeah yeah
he looks great he looks great
that's a giant man they're huge
basketball players you know when they
when they retire and they're that big we
get a shape it's like oh my god oh I get
there's a one athlete whether you cannot
hide him yeah work with Nick Young
that's a good body right there work with
Nick Young really good yes man he he
he's very skinny very thin very six
seven see ya then yeah but they're huge
yeah people realize how big those
basketball players are t seem like holy
he's got a belt like John Jones like oh
yeah yeah you know we didn't uh didn't
grill the old chin chin already I did oh
you did I got this
no she's a kid please I was like but she
didn't ever get you know the ladies stay
in his room Jen yes sir I'm gonna tell
you this lady stays in my room she flies
to [ __ ] Gotham she wants to stay in the
room she ain't just doing it for teeth
the beef sliders I'm taking that as a
sign that she wants the Korean kielbasa
okay now I know you have a problem with
that I think I'll paint the picture
clear I know that you prefer middle-aged
men that you can then come afterwards
between their blood and that's because
you're a serial killer five she wants
your was saw only polite to throw your
wasabi Korean wasabi tainted buffle
wasabi Dom
all right know what we're trying to say
chin is you need to put your eel sauce
in her face there that's that's that's
gonna happen stop is Japanese - gonna
have to ask you Spock has to stop
conflating who you saw Chinese I know
sauces Jack hires you conflating if I
was trying to paint the picture clear
for chin these are very distinct
cultures they're on the history sir okay
let me see this
chin you need to drop
you're nothin her ramen noodles ramen
noodles sounds gross that ramen ooh is
our Japanese - Japanese [ __ ] man
Japanese that she's not Japanese she's
from Africa okay well this is top ten
now dude paint it clear last year's
election
yeah a little afraid of the Africa honey
it's okay but look at me are you afraid
of the African punani you can talk to
Daddy I'm here nobody's listening no
one's listening I'm not afraid of it but
no she's not your style - homie
it was my style your style all right yes
correct your employer's it has a
heartbeat it is I'm not I don't I've
seen some Inuit women and little hard
pass this just all says I'm not gonna
share my seal jerky with there's a
thickness to the torso and then the
short limbed because I'm that's conserve
heat and their face that's not my type
the face takes up all the smells got a
cute they're cute hi are they're
beautiful people but I just I have an in
general and I have an image of maybe I
maybe I'm being ignorant about this but
if you go all the way down sure Sonja
senator yeah so balls this is that big
dick energy kind of over the top though
you know like if you're gonna post a
picture I get y'all rub that thing up I
get but this kind of that game thing
where like dude go come on bro and girls
you know I'm sure DMS are insane but I'm
not that impressed with this daughter I
was gonna say like if you're gonna post
some like that you're gonna post on with
that you should you look skinny though
looks a little yeah it just it's kind of
pointing to the side I'm not that
impressed
you're still long though what the long I
think we you and I do just fine in that
area I don't for sure thank you and I
would have any problem matching that
noise basically as opponent in that
Denis
like it's not like this job and then so
scale one to ten that's a seven right
you gotta you for yeah yeah do for
people like wait is the aroused there's
that just a fat dick hanging out I just
see a pointing I'm just not that
impressed Joe thank you
unless it's coiled up you don't say like
if I call it up like a Cobra so just you
know hey don't do that with your dick
anyway and I'll follow me what are you
doing with the selfie posting that as
far as fast program here's my advisors
kind of McGregor fast I was funny to me
look how many likes it as though like
he's doing to get attention that and it
worked in it yeah kind of a lot of likes
me
marketing 101 gentlemen